- [Instructor] We're already familiar
with the idea of a polynomial
and we've spent some
time adding polynomials,
subtracting polynomials,
and multiplying polynomials,
and factoring polynomials.
And what we're going to
think about in this video
and really start to
is the idea of polynomial division.
So, for example.
If I had the polynomial,
and this would be a quadratic polynomial,
let's say x squared plus three x
plus two, and I wanted to divide it
by x plus one.
Pause this video and think about
what would that be?
What would I have to
multiply x plus one by
to get x squared plus three x plus two?
Well, one way to approach it is
we could try to factor x squared
plus three x plus two
and we've done that
multiple times in our lives.
We think about well, what
two numbers add up to three
and if I were to multiply them I get two.
And the one that might jump,
or the ones that might jump out at you
are two and one.
And so we could express x squared
plus three x plus two as x plus two
times x plus one, and then all of that
is going to be over x plus one.
And so, if you were to take x plus two
times x plus one, and then divide that
by x plus one, what is that going to be?
Well, you're just going to be left with
an x plus two.
This is going, you don't
have to put parentheses,
this is going to be an x plus two.
And if we want to be really
mathematically precise
we would say hey, this would be true
as long as x does not equal,
x does not equal negative one,
because if x equals negative one
in this expression or this expression
we're gonna be dividing by zero.
And we know that leads to all sorts
of mathematical problems.
But as we see, for any other x
as long as we're not
dividing by zero here,
this expression is going to be
the same thing as x plus two,
and that's because x plus two
times x plus one is equal to what we have
in this numerator here.
Now, as we go deeper
into polynomial division,
we're going to approach things
that aren't as easy to do
just purely through factoring.
And that's where we're
gonna have a technique
called polynomial long division.
Polynomial long division,
sometimes known as
algebraic long division.
And if it sounds familiar,
because you first learned
about long division
in fourth or fifth grade,
it's because it's a very similar process
where you would take your x plus one
and you would try to divide it
into your x squared plus three x plus two.
And you do.
Something very, and I'm
gonna do a very quick example
right over here, but we're gonna do
much more detailed examples
in future videos, but you look
at the highest degree terms.
You say okay, I have a first degree term,
I have a second degree term here.
How many times is x going to x squared?
Well, it goes x times.
So you put the x in
the first degree column
and then you multiply
your x times x plus one.
X times x is x squared.
X times one is x.
And then you subtract this from that.
So you might already start to see
some parallels with the long division
that you first learned
in school many years ago.
So when you do that, these cancel out,
three x minus x.
We are left with a two x.
And then you bring down that two.
So two x plus two.
And you say how many times does x
go into two x?
Well, it goes two times.
So you have a plus two here.
Two times x plus one.
Two times x is two x.
Two times one is two.
You can subtract these and then
you are going to be left with nothing.
Two minus two is zero.
Two x minus two x is zero.
So in this situation it divided
cleanly into it and we got x plus two,
which is exactly what we had over there.
Now, an interesting scenario
that we are also going to approach
in the next few videos,
is what if things don't divide cleanly?
For example, if I were to add one
to x squared plus three x plus two,
I would get x squared
plus three x plus three.
And if I were to try to divide that
by x plus one, well, it's not going
to divide cleanly anymore.
You could it either approach.
One way to think about it, if we know
we can factor x squared
plus three x plus two
is say hey, this is the same thing as
x squared plus three x plus two plus one,
and then all of that's
going to be over x plus one.
And then you could say hey,
this is the same thing
as x squared plus three x plus two
over x plus one,
plus one over x plus one.
Plus one over x plus one.
And we already figured out
that this expression on the left,
as long as x does not equal negative one,
this is going to be equal to x plus two.
So this is going to be
equal to x plus two,
but then we have that one
that we were able to
divide x plus one into,
so we're just left with
the one over x plus one.
And we'll study that in a lot more detail
in other videos.
What does this remainder mean
and how do we calculate it
if we can't factor part of what we have
in the numerator?
And as we do our polynomial long division
we'll see that the remainder will show up
at the end when we are done dividing.
We'll see those examples in future videos.